eyes on the objective endued with your
discretion Roger that
for you be certain three two one
right good kill
war is now a first-person shooter half
of you were recruited in malls precisely
because you are a bunch of gamers
anytime day or night
drones are in the sky but whatever
godforsaken place were at war with that
day
you're cleared hot light him up warheads
on foreheads missiles off the rail I'll
go to Hellfire for nothing
would you long 3000 hours in f-16s six
tours 200 combat sorties before you got
so I heard you want to go back to combat
hey honey who wine yeah is it so bad
we're doing we were still making people
safer right
rifle when ready this alert god dammit
what's that
abort negative
don't ask me if it's a just war that's
not up to us to us is just war I am a
pilot and I'm not fine I don't know what
it is that I am doing but it's not fine
words come down the chain we're stepping
up attacks
we got intel says they're stepping up
attacks you ever get to fly in a war or
something
Lewis six Taliban Pakistan just throw it
today
now I'm going on the barbecue
every day I feel like a cowboy taking
potshots at somebody halfway around
quiet what happens when he gets angry
it's more quiet
you just gotta keep compartmentalizing
never mind the compartments got too
close
what is the myth so back combat
I'm okay
you
[Music]